[Musique]
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous on se
retrouve au foyer royal du château de
Versailles pour un nouveau numéro de VIP
en compagnie de Léo Kestel bonjour Léo
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
alors vous êtes professeur agrégé
d'allemand auteurs scénariste vous vivez
à Versailles et si on vous reçoit
aujourd'hui c'est parce que vous avez
récemment paru aux éditions Baudelaire
votre dernier livre Le Manoir de
kerbrooke alors l'intrigue se passe dans
un manoir breton à l'apparence secrète
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière ce lieu
Léo alors ça se passe effectivement en
Bretagne parce que kerbrooke plus breton
que ça tumeur bon et à Versailles aussi
et ce qui se cache dans ce manoir ce
sont des secrets de famille un peu
lourds et ce sont des secrets qui auront
des conséquences terribles sur la vie de
cette famille bien versaillaise de cette
noblesse bretonne qui vient Versailles
alors Versailles on sait que vous vivez
à Versailles la Bretagne c'était aussi
un endroit que vous connaissez bien oui
du côté de ma femme et il y a des
attaches en Bretagne et donc le mot
manoir pour moi a toujours évoqué
quelque chose de mystérieux puis je
dirais que et ça je le dis aussi dans ce
livre tout le monde trouve que la pierre
de granit est triste alors quand il fait
pas beau elle est triste quand il pleut
sur la pierre de granit elle est
luisante à la limite vous pourriez
presque vous voir et avoir peur de
vous-même mais quand il fait beau
vous observez dans les pierres de granit
toutes sortes de couleurs du rose et oui
du rose dans du granite du verre et
c'est une pierre qui change de vie en
quelque sorte en fonction de la lumière
et je trouve que pour illustrer mon
propos il y a pas mieux et justement
dans ce propos vous parlez d'une femme
battue qui cherche à s'émanciper est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un petit
peu et pourquoi cette thématique de la
violence aussi
c'est une question qui qui est difficile
j'ai essayé de de résumer en fait
l'héroïne s'appelle Héloïse bon elle
dépend de son mari parce qu'elle
travaille pas donc c'est lui qui ramène
l'argent au foyer le schéma d'une
société patriarcale finalement c'est ça
c'est tout à fait ça et puis lui il peut
vivre sa vie puisqu'il a plusieurs
usines et quand il n'est pas là il mène
la vie qu'il veut même elle vie privée
qu'elle regarde et elle elle est là à
attendre son mari
à avoir les idées de son mari parce
qu'elle est presque obligée d'avoir les
idées de son mari et puis petit à petit
les choses se dégradent enfin petit à
petit c'est pas vrai parce que la
violence en général dans un couple
s'installe très vite bon et puis il y a
de la violence le mari est violent
dans tous les milieux ça arrive et puis
moi je dirais qu'une femme très
amoureuse au début du mariage ne doit
jamais laisser s'installer ne serait-ce
qu'une petite gifle donc ce couple se
dégrade petit à petit quand elle prend
conscience de sa propre existence à elle
en quelque sorte elle sort de sa
chrysalide
aussi bien sur le plan intellectuel
puisqu'elle va apprendre un métier pour
devenir indépendante que sur le plan
sexuel puisque le désir va renaître elle
va retrouver sa liberté finalement oui
elle va retrouver sa liberté à quel prix
parce qu'une séparation ce n'est jamais
anodin et puis elle a deux de gamins des
adolescents enfin c'est pas des gamins
des grands gamins
et on sait que parfois les adolescents
ça peut être
un tout petit peu pénible d'ailleurs un
jour elle est tellement excédé qu'elle
va voir son confident qui se prénomme
Éloi pour lui dire à Éloi j'ai besoin
d'une coupe de champagne
mais mes ados me fatigue je vais creuser
un trou dans mon jardin et je vais les y
enterrer et c'est comme ça que le début
le livre d'ailleurs voilà exactement
pour revenir sur les enfants justement
parce qu'on a parlé de cette thématique
de la violence mais il y a une autre
thématique qui est importante dans votre
livre c'est celui de l'homosexualité qui
concerne un des enfants et la difficulté
pour certains parents de l'accepter
est-ce que vous vouliez ouvrir justement
à la réflexion avec cette thématique oui
oui à tout prix et surtout à Versailles
enfin quand je dis surtout à Versailles
je vis à Versailles mais enfin vous le
savez aussi à Versailles il y a eu
beaucoup de personnes pour être contre
le mariage pour tous il y a eu à
l'époque aussi beaucoup de personnes
pour être contre le PACS enfin c'est une
société très traditionnaliste bon
j'imagine d'ailleurs que dans toutes ces
personnes qui ont manifesté contre le
mariage pour tous ils ont dû avoir des
enfants qui un jour on fait leur coming
out mais ça j'ai pas de preuve c'est un
vrai sujet de société
mais oui et pour moi
finalement c'est le garçon qui annonce
son homosexualité et dans l'image
paternelle celui qui a des usines celui
qui voudrait que son fils reprenne des
usines et puis qu'il fasse comme à
Versailles des prépas pour devenir ingés
à Versailles on devient ingénieur voilà
et on fait Polytechnique ou je sais pas
les grandes écoles de manière grandes
écoles voilà et alors en plus lui veut
devenir pâtissier et en plus il avoue
son homosexualité le père il faudrait
lui mettre une civière pour qu'il puisse
tout de suite tomber sans se faire mal
se passe mêler de la vie privée
de ses enfants l'avaient privé de ses
enfants les regardent il doit même pas y
avoir un petit sourire en coin pour se
moquer de son fils ou de sa fille qui
est amoureux faut vraiment les laisser
vivre ces moments-là mais qui sont
merveilleux bon et puis la thématique de
du féminisme sans exagérer
moi je trouve que cette femme battue son
mari est absolument inexcusable mais il
ne faut pas non plus à mon sens je
rejoindrai Catherine Deneuve là-dessus
qu'on n'est pas le droit de dire à une
femme qu'elle est belle
alors ce livre c'est le manoir de
kerbroke vous êtes aussi l'auteur de
plusieurs livres dont des best-sellers
vous avez une particularité qui n'est
pas commune chez les auteurs vous êtes
aveugle comment vous composez avec ça
pour écrire visiblement ça ne met pas de
barrière est-ce que je peux faire une
blague
je ne vois rien mais j'ai l'œil
plus sérieusement
j'ai toujours voulu travailler je veux
encore travailler aujourd'hui j'ai
d'ailleurs un roman en cours et une
commande de pièces de théâtre et il ne
fallait pas que le
handicap pardon me clou sur mon fauteuil
en attendant la mort bon non moi je dois
travailler je dois rêver
et j'ai toujours eu une longueur
d'avance sur le handicap et quand je
sens que les choses s'aggravent je
prends les mesures qu'il faut pour
pouvoir continuer mon travail sans
aucune interruption alors qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait j'ai appris le clavier de mon
ordinateur par cœur j'ai trouvé un
logiciel qui s'appelle apprenti clavier
alors la pratique clavier on doit mettre
son prénom Léo vous commencez votre
premier exercice à zer oh c'est très
bien Léo tu n'as réussi l'exercice qu'à
80% tape sur Entrée pour recommencer il
fallait que ce soit bon à 92%. et à
force de répétition
ça fonctionne voilà et puis j'ai
sûrement ordinateur
un système vous savez c'est comme
l'iPhone sur l'iPhone vous avez dans le
menu accessibilité VoiceOver
je peux dicter mes messages je peux lire
mes messages et ben sur mon ordinateur
quand je tape j'entends et puis
j'entends les photos que je commets mais
je commets des fautes comme tout le
monde mais à mon avis je tape aussi vite
que quelqu'un
allait j'allais dire comme vous mais je
vous connais pas donc j'ai pas le droit
de dire ça
alors les autres pièces de théâtre roman
manuel scolaire l'écriture elle fait
partie intégrante de votre vie on l'a
compris comment elle est venue cette
passion pour l'écriture
je sais pas parce que je me souviens ça
ça m'est revenu les vieilles personnes
ont des rêves sur leur jeunesse et je me
souviens que à l'école en fait moi
j'étais au lycée en Suisse je n'ai pas
le bac
d'accord mais je la maturité ça se voit
tous les jours j'ai un maturité qui est
l'équivalent du bac et en fait je me
souviens quand j'étais au collège de
Genève le prof de français me disait
toujours ah là là c'est pas bon c'est
pas bon vous avez quelque chose et j'ai
pas bon et puis un jour il m'a mis quand
même un 12
à l'époque en Suisse c'est pas 12 la
meilleure note c'est un 6 il m'a mis
donc un 4 4 sur 6 on roule à là j'étais
aux anges et puis j'étais à la fac
à Nanterre et j'ai toujours aimé les
médias
et au fond en commençant dans les médias
en Allemagne d'ailleurs petit à petit la
passion de l'écriture m'est venue je
termine ce que je suis un peu bavard
mais je termine j'ai commencé à la
télévision allemande comme porteur de
câbles en studio pour que ça fasse pas
de bruit puis au bout d'un moment j'ai
dit aux producteurs ah je m'ennuie
j'aimerais bien écrire une histoire et
vous m'expliquez comment on la met en
images il m'a dit disparaissait dans la
bibliothèque dans une semaine vous
revenez avec cette histoire
il l'a lu
il a trouvé que il y avait du potentiel
il m'a accordé une journée alors qu'elle
était en plein tournage dans le studio
et il m'a appris comment mettre une
histoire en images
après il m'a dit vous attendez je
propose ça au programme au directeur des
programmes j'ai attendu du mois d'août
jusqu'au mois de décembre je me je t'ai
Thierry ah j'ai rongé mes ongles jusqu'à
l'os et un jour j'ai reçu un télégramme
parce qu'à l'époque il y avait pas de
téléphone et en Allemagne disait zagout
donc très bon vous pouvez écrire
le scénario
et de ce point de départ vous avez fait
de nombreux reportages historiques
culturels vous avez également suivi le
Tour de France cycliste pour la pour la
RD si je me trompe pas vous pouvez nous
raconter un peu comment ça s'est passé
oui alors première chaîne de télévision
allemande mais moi je travaillais pour
la troisième chaîne les 3e chaîne
puisque c'est régional en Allemagne et
en fait un jour j'avais fait un film
historique sur l'histoire est-ce que
vous êtes passionné d'histoire aussi
j'ai passé d'une vie
et j'ai fait un film sur la naissance du
Tour de France en 1903 et la naissance
du Tour de France c'est pas du tout une
histoire sportive c'est une histoire
politique
la rivalité entre deux journaux à
journal qui soutient des refus et un
journal qui est contre dresseur journal
sportif bon
le directeur de la télé avait vu ce
reportage
bon bien un jour je reçois un coup de
fil de la première chaîne qui me dit
tiens est-ce que vous voulez venir à la
présentation du Tour de France à Paris
la société du Tour présente la boucle de
l'année qui va venir
pourquoi oh vous verrez bien allez nez
je viens
j'assiste à la présentation ensuite le
directeur de la télé me dit voulez-vous
venir dîner avec tous les journalistes
c'était donc des journalistes allemands
moi j'ai dit bah oui je parle allemand
ça m'amuse profondément puis tout d'un
coup il prend son couteau il tape sur le
verre et des voilà je vous présente
monsieur costen il va faire une série
qui s'appelle tool tour pas besoin de
traduire
et c'est lui qui va réaliser trois
reportages par étape
culturelle touristique
gastronomique pour accompagner le Tour
de France cycliste et je fais ça pendant
cinq ans alors vous avez été au service
de la télé allemande on l'a compris vous
avez également une carrière dans les
médias en France vous êtes l'auteur de
fiction pour France Inter à faire
sensible ou encore autant en emporte
l'histoire comment elle s'est passé
cette collaboration avec France Inter
oh j'ai pas de mots enfin
j'ai adoré vous l'avez compris peut-être
au son de ma voix j'ai adoré tout ce que
j'ai fait et j'adore tout ce que je fais
encore aujourd'hui sincèrement
un jour on me présente
à l'époque le producteur des fictions
sur un terre c'était un hasard on me le
présente et puis moi en plaisantant je
dis je vous écris une fiction j'en avais
jamais écrit pour inter je vous présente
je vous fais une fiction un polar
et le producteur de me dire
léo je prends au mot dans trois semaines
je la veux sur mon bureau
ça fonctionne beaucoup comme ça chez
vous oui mais oui bah honnêtement notre
métier c'est pas parfois une affaire de
circonstances
alors le tout c'était de tenir la
gageure bon au bout de trois semaines il
reçoit ma fiction qui parlait d'un
meurtre à la fac de 50 heures en
Yvelines où j'étais prof et puis ça a
été diffusé et je vous dire le meilleur
moment pour moi alors c'est l'écriture
évidemment mais c'est quand je suis dans
le studio pour le minutage que tous les
comédiens se sont emparés de mon texte
et qui le disent le métier de comédien
est un vrai métier on peut dire ce qu'on
veut c'est un vrai métier et quand il
s'empare de votre texte
écoutez
c'est narcissique c'est jouissif et
quand j'oublie que c'est moi qui l'ai
écrit alors là je me dis vachement mais
qu'est-ce que c'est bon
et du coup de fil en aiguille j'ai fait
des pôles
j'ai fait des
comment dire des flictions historiques
je parle sur Miro sur l'université que
les nazis avaient créé à Strasbourg
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
sur Niki de Saint Phalle etc quoi encore
de Saint Phalle encore une femme
que je trouve extraordinaire une très
belle femme mannequin et qui a été
violée par son père donc oui c'est une
collaboration je puis je me suis
toujours bien entendu avec les
producteurs
un travail intensif vous savez car moi
je ne peux pas lire
je lis avec mes oreilles donc pour me
cultiver en amont il y a un travail de
fond comme le coureur de fond comme un
marathon avant d'être maître de mon
sujet
d'accord
et alors petite question donc vous avez
une carrière en Allemagne puis en France
comment vous êtes arrivés en France et
plus particulièrement dans le
département des Yvelines et ici à
Versailles bah
on a vécu donc en Allemagne j'étais
détaché au ministère des Affaires
étrangères c'est-à-dire à l'ambassade de
France à l'époque à bonnes bon bah mes
enfants ont baigné dans la langue
allemande que j'aime tant la
musicalement que j'aime tant bon et dans
l'idée de revenir en France j'ai pensé à
mes enfants et à des lycées qui
pourraient les accueillir
parce que à l'étranger on peut pas
rester
plus de fois 6 ans puis moi j'avoue que
je m'entendais pas trop bien avec mon
conseiller culturel et donc j'ai des
missionné parce que j'ai été élu à
l'université qui n'était pas encore
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
qui dépendait à l'époque et de Nanterre
et de Jussieu et en fait du coup ma
fille par exemple a été admise au lycée
franco-allemand de Buc
et par conséquent moi qui était prof à
Saint-Quentin elle qui était au lycée
franco-allemand mais deux garçons là qui
étaient en musique
à rameau au collège Rameau et l'autre
qui était à Auch je me suis installé à
Versailles et vous avez retrouvé ce fort
lien qui a entre les Yvelines et
l'Allemagne
je suis pas retourné là depuis un
certain temps je continue d'ailleurs à
travailler pour l'Allemagne notamment
j'ai un éditeur de livrescolaire en
Allemagne qui continue à me demander des
trucs et puis qui sait je ne vois rien
je vous ai dit mais j'ai l'oeil
peut-être ferais-je à nouveau de la
télévision à l'occasion des Jeux
Olympiques qui sait et bien c'est ce
qu'on vous souhaite dernière question
Léo vous vivez à Versailles donc on l'a
dit vous êtes mécène de l'Opéra royal
quelle est pourquoi pourquoi avoir voulu
vous investir dans cet opéra dans dans
ce patrimoine quai Versailles
me dit mais vous qui aimez tant la
musique pourquoi vous ne devez viendriez
pas mes scènes vous verrez
vous êtes invité à des spectacles vous
vivez la vie d'une association je me
suis dit ah bon comment on fait elle m'a
donné les indications pour m'inscrire et
je suis devenu
de la sociation adore les amis de
l'Opéra royal où je viens régulièrement
comment dire écouter parce que les
spectacles qui sont donnés aussi bien
dans la salle qui joue le foyer qu'à la
chapelle où on donne des musiques
religieuses
c'est de tout premier plan ce qui se
fait ici c'est de tout premier plan et
l'autre jour j'y étais pour la Passion
selon saint Matthieu de Jean-Sébastien
bar je profite d'allemand quand même
barre j'en ai pleuré
tellement c'était beau c'est et en plus
je vois pas mais quand vous entrez dans
la chapelle
je sais pas mais vous êtes quand même
c'est incomparable on a cette chance
quand même à Versailles donc voilà et
si le président de l'association menton
il va pas être content de moi j'ai pas
encore payé ma cotisation de l'année
prochaine ça viendra oui ah oui oui et
bien ce sera le mot de la fin merci Léo
questem de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien et à bientôt pour un nouveau
numéro de VIP
[Musique]